Dax let's talk about hit and run uh yes
you said you got a lot of people you all
should gut your your lovely lady yeah
Claire lady a Christian Bell oh yes yes
yes the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me Kristen Bell is the
leading lady in the movie and I'm sure
you guys always seem she's gonna be on
the show here Wednesday oh very good
right they don't tell me anything I just
do I just sit here in old alive tomorrow
Sly Stone sunomono deflate when he sits
down uh yes she's she's in it which you
know we're a real-life couple yes you
are so I don't know did you do you feel
like our chemistry was was nice
did you enjoy it it felt very forced
it's dead okay great
no you're fantastic you guys are great
together oh thank and uh and it would be
terrible if a real-life couple made a
movie to where they're together in the
movie people said we don't buy it it
that would be terrible is definitely
having more times than not yeah well
very high-rez I thought you guys did a
great job and I'm curious there's a
scene that really stands out where some
of the characters burst into a motel
room and there are some elderly swingers
occasion or vacationers yeah and they
are I think they're probably live
stylers actually not my business right I
can share mine either I do not judge is
Sept but you your characters burst in on
these people and they are not clothed
now they're nude
they're nude and nude nothing's left to
the imagination in that scene is quite
shocking the I heard a rumor I don't
know if it's true that the actors were
not told what they would be seeing no I
don't think you could fake the reaction
that we got from them seeing these folks
for the first time so yeah get it in one
take
you guess well one guy in particular was
a standout very talented this gentleman
um the producer I didn't see him either
the producer came to the hotel room next
to us where we were set up I said how's
it looking over there anything well one
of the guys is very very camera ready
and very camera friendly and he was not
lying there's a guy in this movie that
is 109 pounds and 30 pounds of it is
Wang as you saw his body mass index is
it's overwhelming I hope he wins some
kind of award like a disproportionate or
something you think there's an award
called the disproportion ii yeah i do i
do i do i do who i'm hoping this guy is
safe let's he is he's beautiful in the
film and i actually brought a picture of
he and i at the at the premiere together
this is you guys at the premiere now we
know who is going to him yeah well also
who's he looking at maybe he's me not
the camera you know Bradley Cooper was
at the premiere I think he might be
locked target locked on Cooper's commit
to that photo with me but gob was we
have a clip here from the film and very
quickly you are a guy I want to give
anything away but you were on the run
from some very bad people yes I had to
testify against my very best friend and
he ended up in jail for a while and we
haven't seen each other in four years
and we've just now come together and I
found out some terrible news about him
and I tried to find the silver lining in
it and I'm terrible at it
yeah and this this is your the guy is
out to kill you Bradley Cooper yes all
right let's take a look at this scene
from hit and run you got off what are
you talkin about jail for eight months
oh my god eight months understand what
you're talking about I don't understand
well you can didn't like the gym
equipment it wasn't enough time for you
to read I got in prison because of you
yeah that's horrible I did not
I realize that happen in jail I thought
that was a prison thing yeah well I
guess it's not exclusive to prison is it
a black guy black guy can we just go
okay
so a Mexican guy some of those white
guys as Nazis saw man
Charlie it doesn't matter who violate we
can okay it could have been any number
of people it doesn't matter their race
okay could have been the team Oh have
been tongin could it in Persian was
Filipino
[Applause]